- 「量子情報と計算の理解」へようこそ。僕はJohn Watrous、IBM Quantum Educationのテクニカルディレクターだ。
これはシリーズの第5回目のレッスンで、量子アルゴリズムを扱う第2ユニットの最初のレッスンだ。
このユニットでは、量子情報の計算上の優位性を探っていく。つまり、何ができるのかを
量子コンピュータで実現できること、そして量子コンピュータが古典コンピュータに対して持つ可能性のある優位性について見ていく。
ここでは、分散型の設定ではなく、単一の量子コンピュータで何ができるかに焦点を当てていく。
分散型というのは、例えば複数の量子コンピュータが何らかのネットワーク上で相互作用するような設定のことだ。
実際、分散型の設定にも量子優位性はあって、そこでは通信や暗号が重要な役割を果たす。
でも、このユニットではそういったことについては触れない。
このユニットは、単一の量子コンピュータ上で動く量子アルゴリズムについてだ。
まず自然な疑問から始めよう。量子コンピュータはどんな優位性をもたらす可能性があるのか？
主なものは、量子コンピュータが一部の計算問題に対してより速い解法を提供できるかもしれないということだ。
時間は貴重で、僕たちが日々使っているコンピュータはかなり速いけど、それでもまだ遅すぎる。
ある種の計算問題を解くには、その問題が持つ本質的な計算困難性のせいで。
量子コンピュータが、古典コンピュータでは遅すぎて解けない問題を解けるかもしれないというこの可能性こそが、
過去数十年にわたる量子アルゴリズム研究を本当に牽引してきたものだ。
時間以外にも考慮できる計算リソースがある。例えば計算に必要なコンピュータメモリの量とかだ。
でも、量子コンピュータはメモリの面ではそれほど節約を提供できないことがわかっていて、古典コンピュータのメモリはかなり安い。
特に量子メモリと比べると。だから、ここにはあまり期待が持てない。
計算に必要なエネルギー量といった他のリソースについても考えられる。でも実際には、
古典的に計算するにはほとんどエネルギーは要らない。特に、処理を遅くしてもいいなら。
だから、計算に必要な時間こそが、僕たちの主な焦点だ。
これがこのレッスンの概要で、queryモデルと呼ばれる特定の計算モデルについてだ。
このモデルは、量子・古典を問わず、アルゴリズムのアイデアを発展させるための培養皿のようなものだと思えばいい。
現実の生活で出会うような計算問題を記述する実用的なモデルを意図したものではない。
このユニットの以降のレッスンではqueryモデルから離れ、より実用的な計算の概念に動機付けられたモデルに焦点を当てていく。
でも、queryモデルはとても良い出発点だ。
これは、多くの技術的な細部に邪魔されることなく、量子コンピュータの可能性を探れるシンプルなモデルだ。
また、量子計算の背後にある本当に重要なアイデアや、その仕組みを切り出すことも可能にしてくれる。
実際、量子計算はこのモデルの中で最初に発展し、その中で生まれたアイデアが重要な量子アルゴリズムに直接インスピレーションを与えた。
例えば、因数分解のためのShorのアルゴリズムなどだ。
レッスンの第1節では、queryモデルとは具体的に何なのかを見ていく。
第2節、第3節、第4節では、3つの量子queryアルゴリズム、すなわちDeutschのアルゴリズム、
Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズム、そしてSimonのアルゴリズムについて議論する。これらはますます印象的な優位性を明らかにしていく。
queryモデルの計算において、量子コンピュータが古典コンピュータに対して持つ優位性だ。
queryモデルを説明するために、まずより標準的な計算の抽象化から始めよう。
これは、計算を非常にシンプルで基本的な形で表した図だ。
入力があって、それは通常2進数文字列の形をとる。ただし、必要なら他の記号を使ってもいい。
入力は計算に与えられる。計算はこの図では青い長方形で表されている。
計算の結果として何らかの出力が生成される。これもまた、最も典型的には2進数文字列だ。
もちろん、この図は計算自体がどのように機能するかについては全く具体的ではない。
それを行うために、チューリング機械やBoolean circuit、
または量子計算を考えるなら quantum circuit といった、異なる特定の計算モデルを定式化できる。
確かに、この図は僕たちが日々使っているコンピュータの多くが継続的に入力を受け取り出力を生成しているという事実を表していない。
本質的には、インターネットなどを通じて僕たちや他のコンピュータと相互作用しながら。
でも、ここではそういった相互作用を表現しようとしているわけじゃない。
これは孤立した計算タスクのモデル化についてだ。
例えば、入力はある数の2進数エンコードや行列の表現かもしれない。
あるいは分子の記述、またはその他考えられるものの記述であり、その入力に対して何らかの計算タスクが
実行される。
ここでの重要なポイントは、
入力全体が計算に渡され、入力について何も
隠されていないということだ。
クエリ計算モデルは
異なる仕組みで動く。
クエリモデルでは、入力は関数の形で提供され、
計算はクエリを発行することで
その関数にアクセスする。
言い換えれば、異なる入力に対して
関数を評価することでアクセスする。
ここで図の形で
それを表現したものが見える。
以前見たものと同様に、計算は青い長方形で表されるが、
入力を直接受け取る代わりに
ビット列の形ではなく、質問を投げかけ
答えを受け取ることで
入力にアクセスする。
入力を提供するメカニズムを指すのに、
oracleやblack boxという
用語を使うことがある。
計算複雑性理論ではoracleとblack boxの間に区別があるが、
この議論の目的においては
まったく関係ない。
いずれにせよ、これらの用語は
基本的な考え方を伝えるためのものだ。
古代ギリシャでは、
デルポイの神託のようなoracleのところへ行き、
重要な質問を尋ねることができた。
するとoracleはその特定の質問に答えてくれるが、
知っていること全てを教えてくれる
わけでは決してなかった。
同様に、black boxについて考えるとき、
何らかのプロセスや
システムを想定している。
入力を選択でき出力を見ることができるが、
内部の仕組みについては
何も理解できない。
そしてここでもそれが当てはまる。問題への入力は
関数の形を取り、できることはその関数を
評価することだけだ。
それ以外は、その仕組みについて
知識も理解も持っていない。
このレッスン全体を通して、
入力を表す関数には文字fを使い、
常に次の形を取ると仮定する。
その形はここで見えている
通りだ。
Sigmaは二値アルファベットを表すので、fはビット列から
ビット列への関数だ。
具体的には、fへの入力は長さnの
ビット列であり、出力は長さmの
ビット列だと仮定する。
ここでnとmは正の整数だ。
問題によってnとmに制約があるが、
いずれの場合も入力の関数は
このような形を取る。
計算がクエリを発行すると言うとき、
それは関数fが一度評価される
ということを意味する。
つまり、長さNのある文字列xが計算によって選ばれ、
f(x)という文字列が
計算に提供される。
oracleまたはblack boxによって。そして最後に、クエリアルゴリズムの
計算コストを測る非常にシンプルな方法は
必要なクエリ数を数えることだ。
計算にどれくらい時間がかかるかに
最も興味があるのは確かだが、クエリモデルを研究する際には
一般的にシンプルにして
クエリを数えるだけにする。このレッスンでもそうする。
では、クエリ問題のいくつかの例を
見てみよう。つまりクエリモデルにおける
計算問題だ。
ここでは問題自体を
説明するだけにして、
解き方については今は何も言わない。
最初の問題はOR問題だ。
この場合、入力はnビットから1ビットへの関数であり、
この問題ではmは1に等しい。
問題に対して要求される出力は
1か0のどちらかだ。
f(x)が1に等しくなるようなnビット文字列xが存在するなら、
正解は1だ。
そうでなければ、全ての文字列xに対して
f(x)が常に0なら、正解は0だ。
関数fが2のn乗ビットへのランダムアクセスを提供していると
考えれば、各nビット文字列xに対して
1ビットずつ存在する。
それが求めているのは
それらのビットのORであり、だからこそOR問題と呼ばれる。
別の例はパリティ問題で、OR問題に似ているが、
パリティを求める点が異なる。
言い換えれば、関数の全ての
1ビット出力値の排他的論理和だ。
別の言い方をすれば、f(x)が1に等しくなる
nビット文字列xの数が偶数なら
正解は0だ。
そしてその数が奇数なら
正解は1だ。
mが必ずしも1に等しくない問題の例は
minimum問題だ。
ここで関数fは通常の形を取り、
nとmに制約はない。
正解は、辞書順、つまり
二値文字列の辞書的順序で
最初に来る関数の出力値だ。
あるいは、長さmの文字列を
二進数表記で非負整数として
考えるなら、
正解はこの関数から
出てくる最小の値、
つまり最小値だ。
入力関数に対して何らかの約束、つまり
一種の保証がある
クエリ問題を考えることもある。
そしてその約束を満たさない関数については気にしない。
約束を満たさない関数は「don't care」な入力として扱われる。
そういった入力で何が起きるかについて、こちらは責任を負わない。
「unique search」と呼ばれる約束つきクエリ問題の例を見てみよう。
ORの問題に関連しているが、違うものだ。
入力関数はOR問題と同じ形式で、
nビット列からビットへの写像だ。
今回は、fを1に評価させる文字列Zが
ちょうど1つ存在するという約束がある。
z以外のすべての文字列xに対してf(x)は0で、
正しい出力はこの唯一の文字列zだ。
もちろん、この条件を満たさない関数fの選択もあるが、
そういった場合に対しては一切要件を課さない。
そういった関数が入力として与えられたとき、
アルゴリズムに対してね。
約束を満たす関数についてだけ考える。
さて、今挙げた4つの問題はどれもかなり自然な問題で、
説明しやすく、
解く必要が生じる状況も想像しやすい。でも
クエリ問題の中にはそうでないものもある。
実際、非常に作為的なクエリ問題を考えることもある。
誰かが実際に解きたいと思うか想像しにくいやつだ。
Simonの問題は、レッスンの後半で出てくるが、
この部類に近い。他にも
ある意味ではもっとひどいものもあるが、それでもクエリモデルの研究にとっては
かなり重要なものだということがわかる。
これらの問題を研究するのは、実際に解きたいからではない。
考え方としては、いろいろな極端なケースを探しているんだ。
特に、このPetri dishのようなモデルの中で作業するとき、
量子アルゴリズムのアイデアを探求する自然な方法は
高度に作為的な問題を定式化して、
量子コンピュータの力を最大限に活かせる場を作ることだ。
これが実際、量子コンピュータが
より実用的な場面でどう役立てるかを
大いに明らかにしてくれる。
クエリの概念は、どの計算モデルで作業するかによって
さまざまな方法で形式化できる。
例えばTuringマシンモデルでは、
このシリーズでは触れないが、
そのモデルに適したクエリの概念を
形式化する方法がある。
circuit モデルでは、query gate と呼ばれる特殊な gate を定義して、
それがクエリの正式な表現となる。
Booleanのcircuitの場合、非常にシンプルなやり方があって、
query gate があると想像するだけだ。
画面に見えるように、入力関数を直接評価するやつだ。
アイデアは、これらのquery gateを使って
目的の問題を解くcircuitを組み立てることで、
正しく動作するには、どんな入力関数fが与えられても
正しい答えを返さなければならない。
promise問題の場合は、その約束を満たしていることが前提だが。
nが1のときのparity問題を解く
Booleanのcircuitの簡単な例を見てみよう。
この場合、入力関数fは
1ビットから1ビットへの写像だ。
このcircuitがやることは、2つのquery gateを使って
0と1という入力に対して関数fを評価することだ。
次に、query gateから得た2つの出力値を、
レッスン3のXORを計算するBooleanのcircuitに入れる。
XORはparityと同じものだ。
明確にしておくと、ここにある2つの入力値は
問題への入力ではない、つまりparity問題への入力ではない。
query modelで作業するとき、問題への入力は
関数fで、circuitへのこの2つの入力は
変わることのないハードコードされた値で、
本質的にアルゴリズムの一部だ。
f(0)とf(1)のXORを計算したいから、
この2つのワイヤをこのように初期化している。
こうすることで動作する。ここでは2つのquery gateを使っていて、
これとこれだ。
このBooleanのcircuitが表すアルゴリズムは2つのクエリを発行する。
1ビットから1ビットへの関数のparity問題について考えると
この問題を解くBooleanのcircuitにとって、
少なくとも2つのクエリが絶対に必要だとわかる。
最低でも2つのクエリが要る。
クエリが1つだと、関数fの出力値が1つしかわからず、
もう1つはわからない。実際には何の情報も得られない。
parityについてはね。なぜなら、もう1つの出力値は
0にも1にもなり得て、どちらの解にも繋がるからだ。
つまりクエリ数という観点では、このBooleanのcircuitは
これ以上できないくらい最良だ。
nが1のときのparity問題に対してはね。
query gateについて、次に進む前に触れておく価値のある点がもう一つあって、それはquery algorithmを設計・分析するとき、
query gateがどう実装されるかは
まったく気にしないということだ。
これらのquery gateは与えられるものと
前提されていて、それを構築する難しさは
我々の関心事じゃない。
query gate自体をインプットだと
思えばいい。インプットを作るのは我々の仕事じゃなくて、我々はただ
特定の問題を
インプットが与えられた上で解こうとしているんだ。もちろん、fが1ビットから1ビットへの関数なら、可能な選択肢は4つしかなくて、
そのどれを実装するのも
十分簡単だ。しかし一般に、入力ビットが
多い関数では、
そういった関数のquery gateを
実装するのが極めて難しいこともある。
はっきりしておくと、これはquery gateの
実装方法の問題が重要じゃないということじゃなくて、むしろそれは
query algorithmのコストの
一部とは見なされないということだ。
これは、これが実用的な計算や
実際にcircuitを構築することそのものについてじゃないという考えと一致している。
これは計算について面白いことを
教えてくれる理論的な枠組みの中で
作業することについてなんだ。
このモデルからより標準的な計算モデルへと飛躍するときに、もっと詳しく話す予定で、それが主に次のレッスン、
レッスン6の内容になる。
さて、今度はquantum circuitに
注目しよう。
quantum circuitでは、query gateの
定義をユニタリになるよう変更する。
quantum circuitの中でquery を
行えるようにしたくて、そのためにquantum stateに対して
線形に動作させることで、
superpositionでquery を
効果的に行えるようにしたいんだ。
これはBoolean circuitで
見たことと比べて、queryの意味を変えることでゴールポストを動かしているように
見えるかもしれないが、
その正当性については次のレッスンで
より詳しく議論する。
今のところはただの定義だ。
具体的には、定義は次の通りで、
以前と同じ形の任意の関数fが
与えられたとき、
つまりnビット文字列をmビット文字列に
写すもので、query gate Ufはnプラスmのqubitに作用し、
ここで説明されているactionによって
標準基底状態上で定義される。
この定義を表す図をすぐに見るけど、まず、ここで使われている
記法を明確にしておこう。
それは、同じ長さの2つの
文字列の間の演算としてXORのシンボルを使うときは、
ビットごとのeXclusive ORを
指していて、ここにその例が見える。
定義では、yとf(x)はどちらも長さmの文字列なので、ここにある
この文字列は
この2つの文字列を1ビットずつ
XORして得られる文字列を表していて、これらのgateがどう機能するかを
説明する図がこれだ。
上のn個のqubitは
関数の引数に対応している。
標準基底状態、この図の
|x⟩から始まるとき、その標準基底状態は
変化せずに通過して、
outputの一部としてエコーされる。
下のm個のqubitは関数fの
outputに対応していて、任意の標準基底状態から始まるとき、
この図の|y⟩だが、起こることは
関数f(x)のoutputが文字列yにXORされることだ。
これは標準基底状態で起こることで、
他のquantum stateで一般に何が起こるかを知りたければ、いつもそうするように、線形性を使う。
inputをエコーしてoutputにビットごとのXORを使うというこの形でquery gateを定義する理由は、
これらのgateが関数fの選択に関わらず
常にユニタリだからだ。
これは実際、決定論的な
演算だ。
任意の関数Fの選択に対して
行列として表すと、置換行列が得られる。
つまり各行と各列に1が一つだけあって、
他のエントリはすべて0のものだ。
そして置換行列は
常にユニタリだ。
実際、この演算では
演算が自身の逆になるので、Ufのdaggerはそのままだ。
これらのgateで行いたいのが
ある文字列xに対してf(x)を評価することだけなら、それは簡単で、
yを全ゼロ文字列に
設定すればいい。そうするとyとのeXclusive ORをとると、ただのf(x)になる。
ちなみにここで、全ゼロ文字列を
表すのに使われる記法が見える。
Mの冪乗の0のように見えるが、
それはそういう意味じゃない。
長さがMに等しいゼロの
文字列を意味する。
数ではなく文字列の話をするとき、
指数は通常その文字列を
何回か繰り返すことを意味するので、
これはm回繰り返した0だ。
これはこの文字列を表す便利で正確な方法にすぎない。
改めて言うと、query modelで
作業する際、これらのquery gateをどう
実装するかは気にしない。
それはBoolean circuitの
query gateで抱えていたのと同じ問題だ。
入力を準備するのは我々の仕事じゃない、入力は
これらのquery gateの形で与えられる。
ただし、Boolean circuitを使って関数fを
実装する方法を知っていれば、その実装を
Ufのquantum circuit実装へとかなり直接的に
変換できる。その仕組みは次のレッスンで詳しく見ていく。
余談だが、関数fに対して単一の古典的な
query gateを使い、このように動くBoolean circuitを
作るのはかなり簡単だ。
しかしそれは、このユニタリgate の
quantum circuit実装とはまったく別物だ。
ただ、重要なのは、古典的な
query algorithmにおいて、このように動くquery gateを持つことは、実は
fに対する普通の古典的なquery gateを持つことと等価だということだ。どちらも
もう一方を使って実装できるという意味で。
レッスンのこのセクションでは、Deutschのalgorithmについて説明する。
これは非常にシンプルなquantum query algorithmだが、本当に傑作だ。
このalgorithmはDavid Deutschが1985年に書いた論文に由来する。彼は量子計算の
理論的基盤に取り組んだ最初期の人物の一人だった。
algorithmそのものはDeutschの1985年の論文の
ごく一部を占めているにすぎない。そして実は、
今日Deutschのalgorithmと呼ばれているものは、
実際にはDeutschが記述したalgorithmの改良版だ。
これは量子コンピュータが計算上の優位性を
発揮できるという非常に控えめな例を提供しているが、どこかから始めなければならない。
そして、物事を動かすきっかけとなった
本当に重要な火花だった。
Deutschのalgorithmは、量子計算の文脈でしばしば
Deutschの問題と呼ばれるquery problemを解く。
しかし実際には、1ビットから1ビットへの
関数のparity問題に他ならない。これはすでに話し合ったことだ。
すでに見てきたように、1ビットから1ビットへの関数は4つあり、
その値の表で画面に示されている。
最初と最後の関数は定数だが、中の2つはbalancedだ。
2つの可能な出力値が
同じ回数だけ現れるという意味で。
2つの定数関数では、parityつまり
2つの出力のeXclusive ORが0になるのが分かる。
そして2つのbalance関数では、出力のparityは1だ。
したがって、このparticular caseにおけるparity問題を表す等価な方法、
つまり関数fが1ビットを入力として受け取る場合、
言い換えるとDeutschの問題とは、ここで見るようなものだ。
入力は1ビットから1ビットへの関数fで、fが定数なら出力は0だ。
fがbalancedなら1だ。
すでに示唆した通り、この問題を解く
古典的なquery algorithmはすべて、fに少なくとも2回のクエリをしなければならない。
fの2つの出力値のうち1つしか分からない場合、
2つの出力のparityについての情報はまったく得られない。
ちなみにこれは、ランダム性を利用する
古典的なalgorithmにも当てはまる。
ランダム性はquery problemを解くのに非常に役立つ場合があり、
レッスンの後半でその例を見ていく。
しかしここではランダム性は役に立たない。
したがって、先ほどのalgorithmはDeutschの問題に対する
古典的なquery algorithmの中で最適だ。
次は、単一のクエリでDeutschの
問題を解くquantum query algorithmである
Deutschのalgorithmを見ていく。
こちらがquantum circuitとして
記述されたalgorithmだ。
2つのqubitが
ここに示すように初期化されている。上のqubitはcat 0に、下のqubitはcat 1に初期化されている。
なぜこのようにこれらのqubitを初期化するかは、
すぐに分かる。
2つのqubitにHadamard gateを実行し、
query gateに入力して、上のqubitにもう一つHadamard
gateを実行する。
そしてそれを測定する。そして主張は、
測定結果が確実に問題の
正解を与えるということだ。
では、circuitが正確にどう機能するかを確認するため、
一ステップずつ分析しよう。
Hadamard gateの最初の層の後、2つのqubitの状態は
minus状態とplus状態のtensor productだ。
上のHadamardは0状態をplus状態にマップし、
下のHadamardは1状態をminus状態にマップする。
上のqubitは右にあり、下のqubitは左にある。
これが得られる状態だ。
ちなみに、下のqubitがminus状態にあることは非常に重要だ。
下のqubitを
1状態ではなく0状態に初期化するとうまくいかない。
この状態を半分展開する、
ここに示すように。
今の時点ではそうする理由は
明確でないが、もう少しで便利になる。
次に、query gateが実行された後の
2つのqubitの状態について考えよう。
query gateの動き方は、上のqubitの標準基底状態に対してFを計算し、
その値を下のqubitにXORするというものだ。
そしてここでは、その
結果が見て取れる。
最初の項では、上のqubitの標準基底状態は
0なので、f(0)が下のqubitに
XORされる。
これは線形性によって成り立つ。第2項も同様だが、標準基底状態が
上のqubitに対して1なので、f(1)を下のqubitにXORする。
この時点で、aが0か1のどちらかのときに成り立つ
ここに見えている式を
使って、この表現を
簡略化できる。
この2つの値について別々に確認するだけでいい。
aが0の場合、
aとのXORは何もしないし、-1の0乗は1だ。
つまり両辺は等しい。そしてaが1の場合、XORをとると|1⟩マイナス|0⟩が得られる。
これは-1に
|0⟩マイナス|1⟩をかけたものだ。
その式を使って状態を簡略化すると、左側でaをf(0)に、右側でaをf(1)に
等しくとれる。
すると、ここに見える
式が得られる。
2つの量子状態ベクトルπ1とπ2を比べると、Uf gateがやっていることは
実質的に、f(0)かf(1)の
どちらか一方の値を-1の
指数に置く、
言い換えれば、各項の
phaseに置くということだ。
これが、下のqubitを1に初期化して
Hadamard gateをかけてマイナス状態を作る
理由であり、
これによってこれが起こる。
これはphase kickback現象と呼ばれ、もう少し後でまた別の角度から見てみる。
これはかなり重要で、このレッスン内でも
何度か出てくるし、後のレッスンでも登場する。
今度はマイナス状態を外に引き出して、ここに見える式を得ることで簡略化できる。
余談だが、実際には
ここにはエンタングルメントが
全く存在しないことに
気づくのは興味深い。
どちらの状態も積状態だ。つまり、エンタングルメントは
非常に興味深いが、
この特定のアルゴリズムでは
全く役割を果たしていない。
少し余裕を持てるよう、これを整理しよう。
今度できるのは、-1をf(0)乗した
因子を外に
引き出すことだ。
するとここに見える
状態の式が得られる。
ここを見ると、-1の指数にf(0)とf(1)のXORがある。
-1のf(0)乗の因子を外に出しているので、
f(1)マイナスf(0)になると思うかもしれない。
しかし、XORをとっても
同じ値が得られる。なぜならこれらはビットであり、-1の
指数に整数がある場合に重要なのは
その整数が偶数か奇数かだけだからだ。
この状態を表す別の方法は
ここにあるように、XORの
2つの可能なケースを
考えるだけだ。
そして、測定と一緒に最後のHadamard gateの作用を
考えるとき、状態を表すのに便利な方法だ。
上のqubitに最後の
Hadamard gateをかけると、プラス状態は
0状態に変換される。
そしてマイナス状態は
1状態に変換され、より
簡潔にこう書ける。
そして最後に、測定を行うと、
得られる結果は
f(0)とf(1)のXORになる。
これが求めている値であり、これがDeutschのアルゴリズムの仕組みだ。
かなりシンプルで、何がそれを機能させているのかを考えると、2ビットのパリティを
2回ではなく1回のクエリで計算できる合理的な答えは、
干渉だ。
実質的に、f(0)とf(1)を同時に計算している。なぜなら最初に
Hadamard gateを
上のqubitにかけて、fへの入力を
0と1の重ね合わせにしたからだ。
そしてphase kickbackと最後のHadamard gateによって、本質的に
建設的干渉を作り出している。
正解に対して建設的干渉が起こり、誤答に対して
破壊的干渉が起こる。
つまり誤答は見えず、正解だけが見える。
phase kickback現象について、少し違う角度から見てみよう。
まず、bとcが任意の
二値である、この非常に
シンプルな式を
確認しよう。
要するに、ビットbを値1でXORすることは、bにNOT gateまたはx演算を行うのと同じだ。
そしてもちろん、ビットbを
値0でXORしても何も変わらない。これはbに対して
恒等演算を行うのと同じだ。
そして恒等演算をxの0乗として表せる。
標準基底状態|b⟩テンソル|a⟩の2つのqubitにUf gateをかけると、
Uf gateの定義から、この結果が得られる。
その公式を使えば、ここに見えるように、その状態を別の形で書き表せる。
この公式はbのどんな選択にも成り立つ。だから線形性によって、任意の状態SIに対しても成り立つ
cat bの代わりに。
特に、SIをマイナス状態として選ぶこともできる。
そしてここが、phase x kickback現象が起こる理由の鍵だ。
マイナス状態にx演算を適用すると、マイナス状態の−1倍になるからだ。
数学的に言えば、マイナス状態はx演算の固有ベクトルであり、固有値は−1だということだ。
固有ベクトルと固有値は線形代数においても量子情報においても極めて重要で、これらについてはまだまだたくさん話すことになる
シリーズが続くにつれて。
でも今は、この単純な公式だけが必要だ。
そしてこれを使えば、状態ベクトルを簡略化できる。
まさにあれが、公式として書かれたphase kickback現象の本質だ。
これが成り立つのは、マイナス状態がNOT演算の固有ベクトルであり、固有値が−1だからだ。
これはLesson 7でかなり大きく一般化する。位相推定手順を扱うときで、それがShorの因数分解アルゴリズムを駆動するものだ。
Deutschのアルゴリズムの解析において、この公式が実際に機能するのを次のように見ることができる。
query gateの前の状態は、マイナス状態とプラス状態のテンソル積だ。
次にquery gateを適用し、プラス状態を展開するとこの状態が得られる。
次にphase kickbackの公式を適用してこの式を得て、その後の解析は以前と同様に進む。
以前と同じだが、ここではphase kickbackに焦点を当てることで、それを認識できるようにしている
また、次に出てきたときにも備えられるように。
次は、Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムを扱う。これはDeutschのアルゴリズムの拡張で、実際にいくつかの異なるクエリ問題を解く。
Deutschのアルゴリズムが古典アルゴリズムに対して提供する優位性はかなり控えめで、クエリ1回対2回だ。
Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムはその優位性をある程度高める。何を意味するかは、そこに到達したときに説明する。
Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムは、Deutschのアルゴリズムを自然かつ直接的に拡張する方法と見なせる
1ビットから1ビットへの関数から、nビットから1ビットへの関数、つまりこの形の関数へと。
quantum circuitとして、Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムはこのような形になる。これをDeutsch-Jozsa circuitと呼ぶことにする
このcircuitとDeutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズム自体の間に若干の区別を設けるためだ。古典的な後処理ステップも存在するから。
考え方は、このcircuitを実行して測定すれば、nビット列yが得られるということだ
それが関数fについての何らかの情報を教えてくれる。
ところで、このcircuitで解こうとするクエリ問題が何なのか、実はまだ言っていない。それはすぐ後で出てくる。
でも重要なのは、このcircuitを実行することで、fについての情報が得られ、それがクエリ問題を解く助けになりうるということだ
fが入力である場合に。さっきも言ったように、このcircuitは実際に使える
いくつかの異なるクエリ問題を解くために。
まず、Deutsch-Jozsa問題として知られるクエリ問題を見てみよう。それはDeutsch-Jozsa circuitが
元々解くために作られた問題だ。
Deutsch-Jozsa問題はDeutschの問題の一般化で、与えられた関数が定数関数かバランス関数かを判定することが目標だ。
これはこの形の関数へパリティ問題を一般化する自然な方法ではないことに注目してほしい。
ここではパリティを計算しない。タスクは、関数fが定数関数なら0を出力し、
関数fがバランス関数なら1を出力することだ。
この問題についてまず注目すべきことは、nが（関数fへの入力ビット数）2以上の場合、
定数でもバランスでもない関数の選択が存在するということだ。
例えば、定数でもバランスでもない2ビットから1ビットへの関数がここにある。
出力の中に両方の二進値が現れるから定数ではなく、2つの出力値が
異なる頻度で現れるからバランスでもない。0は3回、1はたった1回だ。
バランスであるためには、出力0と1がちょうど同じ回数現れなければならない。
nが2以上のとき、定数でもバランスでもない関数が存在するという事実は問題ない。そのような関数は
「don't care」入力として扱う。つまり言い換えれば、これは約束問題だ。
そしてここに問題の正確な記述がある。
入力関数fはconstantかbalancedのどちらかであることが約束されていて、目標はどちらなのかを判断することだ。
そして、入力がその約束を満たさない場合に何が起こるかについては、我々は責任を負わない。
この問題を解くDeutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムは、まずDeutsch-Jozsa circuitを実行し、その後0を出力する
測定から得られる文字列がオールゼロの文字列であれば0を出力し、そうでなければ1を出力する。
別の言い方をすれば、測定したビットのORを出力するということだ。
Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムを解析するには、まずHadamard gateについて少し考えてみると役立つ。
もちろん、Hadamard演算は行列として記述できるが、その作用という観点からも記述できる。
標準基底状態への作用として、ここに示すように。
この2つの式は1つの式にまとめることができて、aが2つの二値のどちらであっても Hadamard演算がどのように機能するかを記述している。
そして、もう少し踏み込んで、得られる結果をこのような和として表現することができる。
その式を使えば、n個のqubitそれぞれに1つのHadamard gateを適用する、Hadamard gateの層がどのように機能するかを記述する式を導き出せる。
ここでは、標準基底状態へのこの作用を記述している。
記法を明確にすると、h tensor nをこのように書くとき、tensor nの部分が上付き文字になっているが、
これはHとそれ自身のn重テンソル積、つまりhのコピーn個をすべてテンソル積したものを意味する。
この演算を標準基底状態に適用していて、ここではQiskitが使っている慣例に従っている。
二値文字列のインデックス付けについてで、ちょうどその慣例を紹介するいいタイミングだから。
つまりx0は1ビット、x1も1ビット、以下同様にn個のビットがあって、ビットはここに表示されているような順序になっている。
このビットのインデックス付け方法は、文字列を整数として見たときの桁の重みに対応していると考えることができる。
例えば、二進表記の場合。
これらのqubitそれぞれにHadamard gateを適用すると、結果をn重テンソル積として別の方法で表現できる。
各qubitに適用されたHadamard gateのテンソル積として、次に各テンソル因子にその式を適用できる。
ここでは式中のbの代わりにyとminus 1からy1という名前を使っていて、
これらは二値だ。そして式を使うたびに新しい名前を使うよう注意している。
テンソル積の多重線形性を使ってすべて展開すると、ここに示す式が得られる。
明確にしておくと、n個の和は1つの和にまとめられているが、各二値の可能な値すべてについて和を取っていることに変わりはない。
個々の二値について。
では、もう少し先に進めるよう整理しよう。
次のステップは、二項ドット積と呼ばれる文字列に対する新しい演算を導入することだ。
これは同じ長さの二値文字列に対する演算だ。
同じ長さの2つの文字列xとyの二項ドット積とは、XOR、つまりパリティのことで、
個々のビットの積のパリティだ。
個々のビットの論理積のXORとも言えて、なぜならandは積と同じものだから
二値の場合に。もう一つの言い方をすれば、1か0かは
個々のビットの積の和が奇数か偶数かによって決まる。
文字列を二値のベクトルと考えれば、内積によく似ているが、Modulo-2で計算する点が違う。
つまり、2で割った余りを取るということだ。
ただし、これは本当の内積ではないから、別の名前が相応しい。
今扱っているケースでは、二項ドット積を使って、Hadamard gateの層の作用の式を
標準基底状態に対してより簡潔にできて、ここにそれを示す。
ここで、この和がminus 1の指数に現れているため、
奇数か偶数かだけが重要で、それ以外は基本的に式の凝縮版にすぎない。
ちなみに、二項ドット積はx dot yとy dot xが等しいという意味で対称だ。
だから、便利な場合はいつでも順序を入れ替えることができる。
その式があれば、Deutsch-Jozsa circuitの解析はかなり簡単になる。
n個のqubitを0状態で、下のqubitを1状態で始め、それらすべてにHadamard gateを適用する。
これが得られるn + 1個のqubitの状態だ。
下のqubitは別々に扱っているが、それが便利だからだ。
そしてまた、phase kickback現象が起きるのを見ることになる。
この式は、xに全ゼロ文字列を代入し、yにxを代入する
公式を使って求められる。
全ゼロ文字列と任意の文字列との
二進内積は0になるからだ。
ただ、これは直接的に考えることもできる。n個の|+⟩状態の
tensor積をとると、こうなる。
|−⟩状態のtensorだ。次にUF gateが適用され、
ここでphase kickback現象が起きる。
xの関数値f(x)が、和の中の各xに対して
|−⟩状態にXORされる。
こうしてf(x)がphaseに蹴り込まれる。
次に、上のn個のqubitだけに
もう一層Hadamard gateを適用する。今回は公式が
本当に必要だ。
それを適用して少し簡略化すると、
この状態が得られる。
これが測定直前の
最終的な状態だ。
状態は少し複雑に見えるし、関数fについて
何も分かっていないので簡略化も難しい。
でも覚えておいてほしいのは、
知る必要があるのは測定結果が
全て0になるかどうかだけだということだ。
それが問題に対する答えを決めるからだ。
全ての測定結果が0なら、
関数は定数だと結論づける。
測定結果のどれか一つでも1なら、
関数はバランスだと結論づける。
では、測定から全ゼロ文字列を
得る確率を計算しよう。
それは実際に計算が簡単な唯一の結果だ。なぜなら全ゼロ文字列と
任意の文字列との二進内積は
ゼロになるからだ。ベクトルを見て、
yが全ゼロ文字列の場合を考えると、
測定から全ゼロ文字列を得る
確率についてこの式が得られる。
fが定数の場合とバランスの場合の2通りを考えると、
全ゼロ文字列を得る確率は1になる。
fが定数の場合は1で、fがバランスの場合はゼロだ。
fが定数の場合、和は2のn乗か負の2のn乗になり、
2のn乗で割ると
絶対値の二乗をとると1になる。
fがバランスの場合、和は0になる。
なぜなら、+1と−1が
同じ回数だけ現れて
全部打ち消し合うからだ。
以上だ。Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムは
Deutsch-Jozsa問題を1回のクエリで解く。
エラーはない。全ての演算が完璧に行われると仮定すれば、
毎回必ず正解する。
では、古典的な方法と
比べてどうだろうか？
決定論的アルゴリズムで毎回必ず正解を出すとすると、
最悪の場合、
2のn−1乗+1回のクエリが必要だ。なぜなら
関数を
入力の半数以上にクエリしないと解が確定できないからだ。
2のn−1乗の異なる入力文字列に対して関数をクエリしても、
同じ出力値しか
見えない可能性がある。それは関数が定数だからかもしれないし、
実はバランスだけど
たまたま信じられないほど運が悪くて
毎回同じ出力値を見てしまっているだけかもしれない。
これが量子の古典に対する
大きなアドバンテージだ。1回のクエリ対指数的に多いクエリだ。
ただし、確率的クエリアルゴリズムを使って
誤答の小さな確率を許容するなら、
実際には数回のクエリで済む。
具体的には、k個の文字列を
ランダムに選んでそれらに対して関数を評価すると、
かなりの確率で正しい答えが分かる。
具体的には、毎回同じ関数値が得られたら0つまり定数と答え、
1つまりバランスは
2つの異なる関数値を見たときに答える。
そうすれば、関数が定数の場合は常に正解だ。
当然、この場合は毎回同じ出力値しか見えないからだ。
fがバランスの場合は、2つの異なる出力値を見る
可能性が非常に高い。
この場合に両方の出力値を見られない確率は、
コインをk回投げて
毎回同じ結果が出る確率と同じだ。
例えば、kを11に設定すると、
誤った答えを得る確率は0.1%未満だ。
特に量子コンピュータが現実では決して完璧にはならないことを考えると、
ここではそれほど大きなアドバンテージは得られない。
でも進歩しているし、Deutschのアルゴリズムを超えた
量子の古典に対する定量的なアドバンテージが存在する。
Deutsch-Jozsa circuitを使って、Bernstein-Vazirani問題として知られる
別のクエリ問題を解くこともできる。
その問題の説明だ。入力はnビットから1ビットへの関数で、
Deutsch-Jozsa問題と同様だ。
そしてやはり、これは約束の問題だ。
今回の約束は、関数fがここに示すように動作するような
nビット文字列sが存在するというものだ。
ここで出力は、入力とこの文字列sの
二進内積によって与えられる。
そして目標は単純に
文字列sを見つけることだ。つまり、
文字列sはある意味で隠されていると考えられる。
ただし、fにクエリを投げることで
sについて学ぶことができ、
この隠れた文字列を見つけることが目標だ。
念のため言っておくと、ほとんどの関数は
この約束を満たさないが、いつものように、
満たすような入力関数だけを考えればいい。
実は、Deutsch-Jozsa circuitはこの問題を
そのままの形で解いてしまう。
ある文字列sについてこの約束を満たすような
関数で実行すると、測定によって文字列sが明らかになる。
後処理は不要だ。
では、これがどう機能するか見ていこう。
Deutsch-Jozsa circuitはすでに解析済みなので、
実際には最後まで一気にスキップできる。
これは以前に導出した、測定直前の状態の式で、
任意の関数fに対して有効な式だった。
そして今、関数fについて約束されていることを代入して
整理すると、
下のqubitのマイナス状態と、上のn個のqubitの
cat sのテンソル積が得られる。
つまり、測定するとsが得られる。
ここで示した簡略化を行うためにはいくつかの作業が必要だが、
この動画では詳しく説明しない。
ただし、このシリーズのテキストコンテンツにより詳細が載っていて、
動画の説明欄のリンクからアクセスできる。
あるいは、練習として
自分でやってみてもいい。
まとめると、Deutsch-Jozsa circuitは
Bernstein-Vazirani問題を
1回のクエリで解くということがわかった。
決定的なものであれ確率的なものであれ、
古典的なアルゴリズムは少なくともnクエリが必要であることは
それほど難しくなく示せる。
Bernstein-Vazirani問題を解くために
少なくともnクエリが必要な単純な理由は、
sを復元するためにnビットの情報が必要だからだ。
そして各クエリから得られる情報は
最大でも1ビットだ。
これで、量子クエリアルゴリズムが古典クエリアルゴリズムより優れているという
もう一つの例が得られた。量子アルゴリズムは1クエリで済むのに、
古典アルゴリズムはnクエリ必要だ。
少し立ち止まって、この問題の文脈で使われる
命名法と少しばかりの歴史について話しておく価値がある。
今説明したアルゴリズムをBernstein-Vaziraniアルゴリズムと呼ぶことがあるが、
実際にはそれはDeutsch-Jozsa circuitにすぎない。
そしてそれは実際、
Bernstein と Vazirani の論文でも非常に明確に述べられていたことだ。
Bernstein-Vaziraniアルゴリズムと呼ばれているのは
少し奇妙で、なぜならそれはほぼDeutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムと
同じものだからだ。
後処理がない点を除けばね。ただし、Bernstein と Vazirani は
さらに一歩踏み込んだ。
彼らはこの問題の再帰的バージョンを定義した。
基本的にはBernstein-Vazirani問題のインスタンスを解くことで
複雑な木構造に並んだ
新しいインスタンスのロックを解除していくというものだ。
非常に人工的な問題ではあるが、要点は
このような形で問題を定義することで、
実質的に
量子と古典の間の1対nのクエリ差を
引き伸ばせたということだ。
そして彼らが得たのは、量子アルゴリズムが確率的アルゴリズムに対して
いわゆる超多項式的優位性を持つという
最初に知られた例だ。
Bernstein-Vazirani問題のこの再帰的バージョンは
後になって、別の理由で計算複雑性理論においても
非常に興味深いことがわかった。
いずれにせよ、要点は
Bernstein と Vazirani が重要な貢献に対して
確かに評価を受けるべきということだ。
しかし、これをBernstein-Vaziraniアルゴリズムと呼ぶのは
本当に意味をなさない。基本的には
Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムにすぎないからだ。
レッスンの最後の部分では、
Simonのアルゴリズムとして知られるもう一つの
量子クエリアルゴリズムを見ていく。
このアルゴリズムとDeutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムの間に
明確な類似点があることがわかるが、異なる点もあって、さらに重要なのは、
古典クエリアルゴリズムに対する量子の
はるかに強い優位性を示しているということだ。
具体的には、確率的アルゴリズムも含む古典アルゴリズムに対する
量子アルゴリズムの証明可能な指数的優位性を与えてくれる。
これが解く問題は少し人工的で、この問題を解くことが
役立つ状況を想像するのは難しい。
しかしこれは、Peter Shorが整数の素因数分解のための
量子アルゴリズムを発見する上で
直接的なインスピレーションを与えた。
そしてそのことは、クエリモデルが量子アルゴリズムの
アイデアを発展させるペトリ皿であるという
この考えを非常に強く支持している。
Simonのアルゴリズムが解くクエリ問題から始めよう。
お察しのとおり、これはSimon問題と呼ばれている。
これが問題の記述で、何についての問題かを理解するために
解きほぐしていく必要がある。
最初に注目すべき点は、今回は入力関数fが
nビット文字列をmビット文字列に写すということだ。
ここでmは一般に1と等しくない
何らかの正の整数だ。
これは約束問題だ。Bernstein-Vazirani問題と同様に、約束には文字列sが含まれていて、それを隠れた文字列と見なせる。
そしてBernstein-Vazirani問題と同様に、
目標はこの隠れた文字列sを
出力することだ。
ただし今回は約束がより
複雑なので、分解して
何を言っているのか理解しよう。
まず読んでみよう。長さがnに等しい
文字列sが存在すると書いてある。
そして特定の「ならば」かつ
「その場合に限り」という条件が、nビット文字列xとyの
すべての選択に対して成り立つ。
具体的には、f(x)がf(y)に等しいのは、
2つの可能性のうち
どちらかが成り立つ場合に限る。
最初の可能性はxがyに等しい場合で、
2番目の可能性はxのビット単位
排他的論理和を取ることで
隠れた文字列sと計算すると、yが得られる場合だ。
これはかなり厳しい約束だということが
わかる。ほとんどの関数は
この条件を満たさない。
この条件を満たすのは
非常に特殊な関数だけだ。
さて、この約束、そして問題自体を
より深く理解するために、
2つの主要なケースを考えよう。
最初のケースは、sが
全ゼロ文字列の場合だ。
この場合、約束の中の「ならば」かつ
「その場合に限り」という文を
簡略化できる。なぜなら、任意の文字列xの
ビット単位排他的論理和を
全ゼロ文字列と計算すると、
単に文字列x自体になるからだ。
だから条件は簡略化されて、
f(x)がf(y)に等しいのは
xがyに等しい場合に限る、となる。
これはfが全単射関数だと
言う別の表現に過ぎない。
言い換えると、f(x)の文字列は
各可能な文字列xに対して
一意でなければならない。
つまりfが全単射関数なら、約束は
確かに満たされる。具体的には
sが全ゼロ文字列の場合で、
そしてこの場合、それが
正しい出力だ。
2番目のケースはsが
全ゼロ文字列でない場合で、
このことが意味するのは関数fが2対1でなければならないということだ。
つまり、すべての入力文字列xに対して、
fがxと同じ文字列に写す
別の文字列がちょうど1つ存在する。
さらに、その別の文字列は
xとsのビット単位
排他的論理和を取って得られる文字列でなければならない。
別の言い方をすると、すべての
nビット文字列xにはパートナーがあって、
そのパートナーは
sとのビット単位排他的論理和を
取って得られる文字列だ。
任意の2つのパートナーをfに
代入すると同じ出力文字列を
与えなければならず、他の文字列がその
同じ出力文字列を与えることは許されない。
だからパートナーが生成する文字列は
必然的に異なる文字列になる。
これはその値の表で記述された
そのような関数の例だ。
これは3ビットから5ビットへの
関数だ。
この値の表をしばらく
眺めると、約束が文字列011に対して
満たされていることがわかる。
000と011はパートナーだ。どちらか一方を
sでXORすると他方が得られる。
そして同じ出力値を取る。この
特定のケースでは10011で、
他の文字列はその同じ出力文字列を生成しない。
001と010はパートナーだ。なぜならどちらか一方を
sでXORすると他方が得られて、
同じ出力値を生成するからだ。
その値は再び、他の
文字列では生成されない。
同様の状況は100と111、
そして101と110にも
当てはまる。
つまり、問題への入力が
この関数なら、正しい答えは
文字列011だ。
前に言ったように、ほとんどの関数は
この約束を満たさない。非常に
特定の条件だ。
また、約束が満たされる場合、
それは1つの文字列sに対してのみ
満たされることも注目すべき点だ。
だからこの問題には常に
正しい答えが1つだけある。
以上がSimonの問題だ。前に言ったように、
この問題を解きたいと思うような
実用的な状況を想像するのは難しい。
でもそれは要点じゃない。要点は
量子コンピュータが何が得意かを
理解しようとすることで、
それらははるかに優れていることがわかる。
この特定の問題を解くための
古典的アルゴリズムより
圧倒的に優れている。
では、Simonの問題を解く
Simonのアルゴリズムを
見てみよう。
このアルゴリズムは、ここで見える
quantum circuitを何度か実行することと、
その後の古典的な後処理ステップで構成される。
「何度か」が具体的に
何を意味するかは少し後で
説明する。
このcircuitはDeutsch-Jozsaの
circuitに非常によく似ている。今回は関数fがnビットから
mビットへ写すため、
query gateが異なる。下に1つの
qubitだけではなく、下にm個の
qubitがある。
そして上にはn個、
以前と同様だ。
重要な違いは、下に
マイナス状態や複数のマイナス状態を
設定していないことだ。
これらの下のqubitはすべて
0状態に初期化されていて、
それらの状態がそのまま
query gateに入る。
このアルゴリズムにはphase kickbackは関係ない、そういう仕組みじゃないんだ。
ただ、今言った違いを除けば、
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
にかなり似てる。
Hadamard gateの層を適用して、query gateを一度適用して、さらにもう一層
Hadamard gateを適用する。
その後、上位n個のqubitを標準基底で測定する。
このcircuitを実行して測定するたびに、
隠れた文字列sについて何かを教えてくれる
文字列yが得られるんだ。
Simonの問題でね。そしてcircuitを
独立に何度も実行することで、sについて
十分な統計的証拠が集まる。
そうすれば、高い確信を持って
それが何かを特定できるようになる。
では、Simonのアルゴリズムの量子
circuitを分析して、何をしているか見ていこう。
最初のHadamard gate層の後の
状態はこうなる、Deutsch-Jozsaアルゴリズムで
見たものに似ている。
ただ今回は、下位m個のqubitが
すべて0の状態にあり、
マイナス状態ではない。
query gateが実行された後、f(x)の値が
下位つまり左側のm個のqubitに
書き込まれているのがわかる。
f(x)が全ゼロ文字列にXORされているから
そうなるんだ。
だからやはり、このアルゴリズムではphase kickbackは起きていない。
次に、第二層の
Hadamard gateを適用する。
そして、以前と同じ公式を使って、
標準基底状態cat xに対する
Hadamard gate層の作用を求める。
元の公式と同じように、この状態が得られる。Hadamard gateの作用が
より明確になっている。でも必要なら、
ここにあるようにより compact な形式で
状態を書き直すこともできる。
この時点で、上位n個のqubitを測定してnビット文字列yを得る。あとは確率が
何かを求めればいい。
異なる文字列について確率を求める。
そうすれば、文字列yから文字列sについて
どんな情報が得られるかわかる。
sは関数fの中に隠れている。
これにはもっとスペースが必要で、
circuit図はもう必要ないから
消して、分析のために
もっとスペースを確保しよう。
測定直前の状態はこれだ、
上位つまり右側のn個のqubitの
標準基底測定をする。
この測定は
第二のcatに対応する。
各yに対して、測定で文字列yが得られる確率をp(y)と表そう。
Lesson 2のルールに従うと、
これらの確率それぞれは、量子状態ベクトルの
標準基底状態にテンソル積されているベクトルのユークリッドノルムの二乗になる。
yに対応する
量子状態ベクトルの。
そうするとここにあるこの式が得られる。
これらの確率をより良く理解するために、
ある記法を使う必要がある。
この記法はもう知っているかもしれない。
数学ではかなり一般的だから。
まず、関数fの値域と言うとき、
単純にこの関数から出てくる
すべての文字列の集合を意味する。
つまり、入力文字列xの
すべての選択肢にわたる
f(x)の全集合だ。
次に、ここにあるこの記法を使う。
これは、与えられた文字列zにfが
写す入力文字列xの集合を意味する。
どんなzを考えるかに関わらずね。
関数fの逆に見えるけど、
実際には逆じゃない。fが
必ずしも可逆とは限らないから。
左辺の引数として集合があるのもわかる。
この場合、単一の文字列zだけを含む集合で、
それがfの逆について話しているんじゃないと
認識するためのヒントになる。
これは原像(pre-image)と呼ばれる。
原像はより一般的に定義できる。
単一の要素を含む集合だけでなく、
引数として与えられた任意の集合に対してね。
ただし、必要なのはこれだけだ。
世界最高の記法というわけじゃない。
逆と混同しやすいから。
でも十分わかりやすくて広く使われているから
これを使っていく。
この記法を使えば、
各文字列yを測定する確率を求めるための
ユークリッドノルムの二乗を取るベクトルを書き直せる。
これをするのは、各個別の標準基底状態の
係数を見る必要があるからで、
ここにあるこの式からは明確じゃない。
一般的に、同じ文字列f(x)を与える
xの選択肢が複数あり得るから。
本質的には、xの総和を分割しているだけで、
まずfの値域のすべてのzについて
総和を取る。
そしてその総和の内側で、zの原像の
すべてのxについて総和を取る。より正確に言えば、
文字列zを含む集合の
原像について。
そうすればcatの中のf(x)をzに
置き換えられる。
そして各zにfが写す異なる文字列x
すべての総和が、各catの
係数にまとめられる。
基本的には文字列をビンに入れて、
ビンについて総和を取り、
各ビンの文字列について総和を取っている。
でも、それはすべての文字列を
足し合わせることと等価だ。
つまり、最初に出発した式と
等価な式が得られる。
そして今、ユークリッドノルムの
2乗を計算できる。
それは係数の絶対値の2乗の和に過ぎず、
ここでこの式が得られる。
確率として。
もちろん、これを自分で検証してみる時間を
取ってほしい。時間をかけてもいい。慣れるまでに時間がかかる。
そしてこれらの計算を
こなせるようになるには、練習すればするほど楽になっていく。
これまで、Simonの問題における
promiseをまったく使っていなかった。
この確率の分析は実は任意の関数fに対して成り立つが、
今度はSimonの問題を具体的に考える時だ。
以前と同じ2つのケースに
分けて考えていく。
最初のケースはsがすべてゼロの文字列の場合で、
2番目のケースはsがすべてゼロの文字列ではない場合だ。
最初のケース、つまりsが
すべてゼロの文字列の場合、話は単純だ。
この場合、前に見たように、fは全単射な関数なので、
1つの文字列xが存在して
fの値域にある各文字列zに
写像される。
それにより、その文字列の和の絶対値の2乗は1になる。
なぜなら和の中に項が1つしかないからだ。
それは+1か-1のどちらかだが、どちらでも構わない。
絶対値の2乗を取るので、1が得られる。
fの値域には2のn乗個の要素があり、
それはfが全単射なので分かっている。つまり入力文字列ごとに値域に1つの文字列がある。
式全体を評価すると、各文字列yが
確率2のn乗分の1で現れることが分かる。
つまり言い換えると、測定により
一様ランダムに選ばれた文字列yが得られる。
これはあまり役に立たないように見えるかもしれないが、
実はこの挙動を、次のケースで得られる挙動と
区別できるようになる。sがすべてゼロの文字列ではない場合だ。
それがどうなるかはすぐに見ていく。
ただ今のところ、sがすべてゼロの文字列の場合に
fがSimonの問題のpromiseを満たすならば、
測定の結果は一様ランダムな文字列になる
ということを確認しておく。
では2番目のケースに移ろう。
すべてゼロではない文字列sに対してpromiseが満たされる場合だ。
この場合、前に議論したように、fの値域にある各文字列zに
写像される文字列はちょうど2つある。
すべての文字列にパートナーがあり、各ペアのパートナーが
ある一意な文字列に写像されるからだ。具体的に、各文字列のパートナーは
sとXORして得られる文字列だ。
だからfの値域にある任意の文字列zを選んで、
fがzに写像する2つの文字列のうちの一方をwと名付けると、
wとsのXORが
zに写像される他方の文字列になる。
和の中で、念頭に置いている値域の文字列zに対応する
1つの項だけに注目すると、
ここに示すように、
より明示的に書けることが分かる。
zのpre-imageには2つの文字列がある。wとsとXORしたwだ。
だから画面に示すように和を書けて、
今できることは負の1のw・y乗という因子を
括り出すことだ。
その因子は+1か-1のどちらかなので、
絶対値を取ると消えて、
残るのは
この式だ。
詳細はここには全部示されていないし、
こうなることは必ずしも自明ではないが、
この2つの式が等しいことは
二進ドット積の定義に立ち返って、
これらが負の1の指数にある場合に何が起きるかを
考えることで確認できる。
Bernstein-Vazirani問題で
扱ったものと似ている。
最後に、この式を
2つのケースに分けられる。
sとyの二進ドット積が0の場合は4で、
sとyの二進ドット積が1の場合は0だ。
特に注目してほしいのは、ここにはwやzへの依存が
まったくなく、sとyにのみ依存するということだ。
これが起きる理由は、
promiseの非常に特定的かつ特殊な性質にある。
本質的に、これがpromiseがこのように
定式化された理由であり、すべてがうまく合うようになっている。
繰り返すが、すべての文字列にパートナーがあり、
それはこの1つの隠れた文字列sとXORして得られる。
そしてそれがこのすべてを
起こさせている。
今、確率の式に戻って
値を代入できる。
sがすべてゼロの文字列ではない場合、fの値域には
2のn-1乗個の要素があり、
これは入力文字列の数の半分で、
先ほど計算した値を代入すると
ここの公式が得られる。
つまり今回、yは完全にランダムな文字列ではなく、
nビット文字列のちょうど半分に対して一様に分布している。
特に、sとの2進内積が
0に等しい文字列に対して
一様分布になっている。
Simonのアルゴリズムのcircuitがどう動くか、
そして具体的に各測定結果の
確率がどうなるかがわかったところで、
これがSimonの問題を解くのに
どう役立つかを説明しなければならない。
今学んだことをまとめると、関数fが
Simonの問題の約束を満たす場合、
隠れた文字列sが全ゼロ文字列のときは、
測定から完全にランダムな
文字列が得られる。
nビット文字列yは
それぞれ等確率だ。
一方、関数fが全ゼロ文字列でない
別の文字列sに対して
約束を満たす場合は、
sとの2進内積が0に等しいランダムな
文字列yが得られ、そういった文字列の中で
各yは等確率だ。
ただし、sとの2進内積が
1に等しい文字列yは
絶対に得られない。
問題は「これだけの情報でsを
特定できるか？」ということだ。答えは、
すでに示唆したように、イエスだ。
ただし、circuitを
十分な回数実行する
必要がある。
具体的には、circuitをk回実行すると
仮定しよう。ここでkはn＋rに等しい。
rはsを復元できる
可能性を制御する
ある数だ。
例として、rを10に選べば、
99.9%を超える確率で
成功する。
だからrをそんなに大きくする
必要はない。
一般に、失敗の確率は、公平なコインをr回投げて
毎回表が出る確率より
小さい。
99.9%では不十分なら、
rを20にすれば失敗の確率は
100万分の1未満だ。
あるいは自分が納得できる
rを選べばいい。正しい解を保証することはできないが、
誤りの確率を無視できるほど
小さくすることはできる。
ここではこれらの文字列をy1からykと
名付けている。上付き文字を使って
文字列を区別しているのは、
下付き文字を各文字列の
個々のビットを指すために
使いたいからだ。
これらは指数でも何でもなく、
ただk個の文字列につけた
名前に過ぎない。
各文字列の長さはnだ。
Simonのアルゴリズムのcircuitを
実行して得たものだから。
これらk個の文字列の
個々のビットは、ここに見えるように
書き下せる。
次にやることは行列mを作ることだ。
この行列の各要素はビットで、
測定した文字列から
得られる。ちょうどここに
示した通りだ。
この行列はk行n列で、
全ての要素は2値だ。
今、sが何かはわからない。
それこそ求めようとしているものだが、
sがわかっていると仮定してみよう。
そして、ここに示すように
sのビットから列ベクトルを
作ったとしよう。
そのベクトルをmで掛けて、
結果を法2で取ると、
別の言い方をすれば
加算を排他的論理和に置き換えると、
必然的に
全ゼロベクトルが得られる。
それは、この結果ベクトルの
各要素がsとmの
各行との2進内積に
他ならないからだ。
sが全ゼロ文字列の場合、
2進内積から常にゼロベクトルが得られる。
sが全ゼロ文字列でない場合も、
y1からykの文字列が現れる確率について
わかっていることから同じ結果になる。
特に、これらの文字列全てについて
sとの2進内積は
常にゼロだ。
簡単に言えば、sのビットから作ったこの
ベクトルは常に行列mの
null空間に属する。
全ての演算を法2で行うという
前提だが、もちろんsは
わかっていない。
sを求めようとしているのだ。
でも、できることがある。
行列mのnull空間を
法2で計算できる。
具体的には、ガウスの消去法という
手法を使って
それができる。これは
入門線形代数の講義で
よく教えられる方法だ。
全演算を法2で行っても
うまくいき、コンピュータで
効率よく実行できる。
mのnull空間を計算すれば、
これらk個の文字列が
ランダムに選ばれた特定の方法から、
1マイナス2の負r乗より大きい確率で
sを復元できる。
具体的には、1マイナス2の負r乗より大きい確率で
見えるのは、null空間が
全ゼロベクトルを含むということだ。
これは全ての行列で常に成り立つが、
加えてsに対応するベクトルも含む。
それが全ゼロベクトルかどうかに関わらず。
そして最も重要なのは、他のベクトルは
null空間に現れない
ということだ。
これは実は難しくない証明だが、
詳細には立ち入らない。
考え方はこうだ。全ゼロベクトルでも
sでもない別の文字列があるとすると、
ランダムな文字列y1からykの
各々が、それを1/2の確率で
null空間から弾き出す。
k回試した後では、
生き残る可能性はほぼなく、
属していない文字列は
どれも生き残りにくい。
確率論の非常に単純な事実、
union boundと呼ばれるものを使ってそれを示せる。
全ての詳細を説明したわけでは
ないが、行列mのnull空間を
法2で計算することで、
高い確率でsを復元できる、
というアイデアは
掴んでもらえたと思う。これがSimonのアルゴリズムがSimonの問題を解く方法だ。
Simonの問題について
言うべきことがもう一つある。
それはこの問題の古典的な困難さだ。
つまり、古典的なクエリアルゴリズムが
Simonの問題を解くには
何回クエリが必要か？
答えは、一般に、
たくさん必要だ。
この問題の古典的な困難さについては、
さまざまな精密な言い方ができる。
その中の一つを紹介する。
任意の確率的クエリアルゴリズムが、
2のn/2乗マイナス1マイナス1回
未満のクエリしか行わない場合、
これはnについて指数的な
クエリ数だが、そのアルゴリズムは
Simonの問題を解けない。
少なくとも1/2の確率で
失敗する。
こういった不可能性の結果を証明するのは
非常に難しいこともあるが、
これはそれほど難しくない。
初等的な確率論的分析で
証明できる。
このビデオレッスンではその証明はしない。
代わりにその背後にある
直感だけを説明する。
隠れた文字列sを探しているわけだが、
同じ出力値を持つ2つの文字列に対して
関数をクエリしない限り、
sについて得られる情報は
非常に限られる。
基本的にわかるのは、
隠れた文字列sがクエリした
任意の2つの異なる文字列の排他的論理和でない
ということだけだ。
この数より少ないクエリで関数をクエリしても、
sの選択肢はまだたくさん
排除されずに残っている。
これは厳密な証明ではないが、
基本的なアイデアはそういうことだ。
まとめると、Simonのアルゴリズムはクエリモデルにおける
量子アルゴリズムの古典アルゴリズムに対する
顕著な優位性を示している。
特に、Simonのアルゴリズムは
関数への入力ビット数nについて
線形なクエリ数でSimonの問題を解く。
一方、どんな古典アルゴリズムも、
たとえ確率的であっても、
nについて指数的なクエリ数が必要だ。
それなりの成功確率でSimonの問題を
解くためには。
確かにSimonの問題は
誰も本当に解きたいとは思わないような
やや人工的な問題だ。
でもそれは二次的なことだ。
アイデアは実用化される前に
開発される必要がある。
実際、Peter Shorは、
Simonのアルゴリズムが自身の
有名な量子アルゴリズムに
触発されたと明言している。
そのアルゴリズムは整数の素因数分解のためのもので、
数回後のレッスンで見る。
以上でレッスン5を終わる。
このレッスンでは、計算のクエリモデルを
見てきて、古典アルゴリズムに対する
優位性を示す量子アルゴリズムの
例の流れを
このモデルの中で
見てきた。
実はクエリモデルや、
ここでは取り上げなかった他の問題に対する
量子アルゴリズムについて
知られていることはもっとたくさんある。
このモデルが面白いと感じたなら、
まだまだ学ぶことがある。
次のステップはクエリモデルから離れて、
より実践的な問題を解くのに
ふさわしい計算モデルへ
向かうことだ。
レッスン6でも一緒に学んでほしい。
そこでは主に量子アルゴリズムを研究するための
基礎を築くことに集中する。
それから、具体的な量子アルゴリズムへと
進む。整数の素因数分解のための
Shorのアルゴリズムを含む。
それは以降のレッスンで扱う。それまでさようなら！